The Cold War explained, like you are five.
Step one, in 1945, the war ends,
and the two countries that won it
are already suspicious of each other.
American soldiers and Soviet soldiers shake hands
in the middle of a ruined Germany,
and then they draw a line and stop.
The Americans have something new.
In August, they dropped two atomic bombs on Japan,
and the war in the Pacific ends in nine days.
For four years, only one country on Earth has that weapon.
They did not become enemies because of what they believed.
They became enemies because one of them
was holding something.
In 1949, the Soviets test one of their own.
Step two, now both of them have it,
and both of them keep building.
By the 1980s, there are more than 60,000 nuclear weapons
in the world, and that creates a strange rule.
If either one attacks, both of them die.
So the two most heavily armed countries in history
never fight each other, not once, not one battle.
Instead, they fight everywhere else
through other people's countries
with other people's soldiers.
Korea, Vietnam, Angola, Afghanistan.
The weapon that made the two of them safe from each other
made everybody else the battlefield,
and in one city, the line runs straight down
the middle of the street.
Step three, Germany is split in two,
and Berlin sits deep inside the Soviet half
and is itself split in two.
For years, people simply walk across,
and the ones who walk west mostly do not come back.
Doctors, engineers, teenagers.
So on the night of the 13th of August, 1961,
without warning, soldiers roll out barbed wire
across the streets while the city is asleep.
People wake up on the wrong side of their own city.
The wire becomes a wall.
The wall gets a second wall
and a strip of sand between them
where anyone crossing can be seen.
It was not built to keep an enemy out.
It was built to keep its own people in.
For 28 years, that wall is the safest place in the war
because the dangerous part
is happening somewhere nobody can see.
Step four, October, 1962.
The Soviets put nuclear missiles in Cuba,
and for 13 days, the world sits closer to the end
than it ever has.
That one gets solved by two men making a deal.
The others get solved by luck.
On the 26th of September, 1983,
a Soviet early warning system
reports five American missiles incoming.
The officer on duty that night
is supposed to pick up the phone and report an attack.
He decides the computer is wrong
and reports a malfunction instead.
He is right.
Everybody was afraid of a machine deciding to end the world.
It nearly ended because a machine was believed.
The war does not end in a battle.
It ends in an accounting office.
Step five, the Soviet Union is spending
enormous amounts of money on weapons, on Afghanistan,
and on holding half of Europe.
Then the price of oil collapses, and oil is what it sells.
It is running out of money,
and the countries it controls start pulling away.
On the 9th of November, 1989,
an East German official is handed a note
about relaxing the travel rules
and reads it out at a press conference
without reading it first.
A journalist asks when this takes effect.
He looks at the paper and says, immediately.
Within hours, thousands of people are standing at the wall
and the guards, with no orders,
and nobody answering the phone, open it.
For 40 years, two countries pointed 60,000 warheads
and never fired one.
The thing that finally opened the border
was a man who did not read his notes.
And that's just one story inside Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers,
download it now and become the most intelligent person
in the room.